hello I'm s not want way and I'm from
allowing I'm part of a network of global
changemakers from around the world who
were recently here in Cape Town to have
a discussion one of the issues that
affect them and their country the 2010
question is a very good question to ask
and I feel that 2010 even though it is
in South Africa the effects of it will
ripple around the countries in at the
rest of the countries in Africa and this
is mainly because coming from Malawi the
world cup as itself the world cup it's
the world cup so many people from around
the world will be coming here South
Africa cannot contain the whole world so
teams will be training in other parts of
especially sub south southern Africa so
Malawi is one of them so we'll have many
teams coming in to train on our fields
which will bring in what a lot of
tourists which will bring in recognition
of the country as a whole and we shall
bring in benefits so even though the
world cup as itself the cup is in South
Africa the effects of this world cup
will be solved all over Africa